hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna keep working on our brain computer
app we have all of our phase 1
functionality working but it doesn't
look very good so we need to style it a
little bit just make it look a little
bit nicer it doesn't have to be like
amazing right but we want to look a
little bit better and if we get through
that today then we're gonna do whatever
else we need to do to get it ready to
actually go to the Google Play Store
we're gonna launch this first as an
Android app later on on iOS I happen to
have an Android phone so that's why I'm
doing Android first and I'm on a PC
uh-huh so I I do have a Mac that I can
use to launch this as an iOS app as well
but it's not as good for streaming so
we're gonna try this first as an Android
app since the last time we streamed I
did install Android studio so we can
simulate the Android app right now I'm
just gonna stay in the the web mode
because it's easier to work with when
we're styling but at some point when we
need to we can also check out the the
simulator in Android studio ok so I see
there's a lot of you here and a lot of
you been waiting for a long time I
notice a few you are in time zones to
where it's like I don't know 2 a.m. 3
a.m. something like that I apologize for
that
I am I used to be able to stream earlier
in the day to accommodate time zones
especially the time zones like if you're
in India or you know time zones in that
area but unfortunately I have to work
during that time period now so it's kind
of hard for me to accommodate I guess if
I waited till even later like towards
night time here in my time zone I it
would be maybe morning there's just not
really a time that I can stream that
would come
all timezone so let me know if this is a
very awkward time for you and I'll keep
that in mind but I guess probably the
best thing for me to do maybe is just
try to do different times when I can so
that you can always watch the recording
but you know maybe sometimes you can
catch it live if I switch up the times
one other thing I wanted to to tell you
all before we get started with the code
you may have noticed that part two is no
longer available so this is part 4 of a
streaming series part two is not
available so after trying to figure out
what happened to part 2 my best guess as
to what happened is that I accidentally
deleted it so I'm very sorry about that
I'm not I don't really remember deleting
it for sure but what I do remember is
that before the last stream like right
before the last stream I was trying to
set the stream up and I accidentally
created the stream with basically like
no scheduled start time which means the
stream would be scheduled to start
immediately and then I quickly realized
my mistake and started a new stream
tried to start a new stream with the
same name that would have the correct
start time and I wanted to quit that old
stream basically delete the old stream
so I wouldn't confuse people who were
thinking that it would start immediately
and what I think happened is that I
thought I was deleting that that stream
that should have never been created but
in reality I maybe deleted the wrong
stream and I'd really did the second one
that's what I think happened the reason
I think that is because after I finished
that stream which is stream 3 I went
back and saw that the duplicate of
stream 3 was still there and it had
never been deleted and so I'm thinking
maybe that's what happened I tried to
contact YouTube through the feedback
like their feedback modal on like
creator studio is like the YouTube
kind of like admin panel for four
creators I tried sending a message there
I don't really know if they'll get
around I don't know if they even would
put like recreate that video I know it's
possible I've read online that it
happens sometimes that they will
recreate the video but I'm not 100% sure
like free code camp doesn't monetize so
I don't know I don't know how Google
would view that if it would you know
I've heard that they do it for large
channels this is kind of a large channel
but I don't know so we'll see I'm kind
of expecting that that video will never
come back so I really apologize for that
I mean I like I had to read everything I
could and do whatever I could to try to
get it back but it's I think it's out of
my hands at this time so anyway that's
what happened to number two I did have a
few people ask about it so I figured I
just you know let everybody know so
let's go ahead and and get started and
like I said we're gonna do some styling
we may also add in you maybe clean up
the code a little bit if I notice
somewhere where we could clean it up
it's still very simple though we've
managed to do everything all in one file
but we do have some places where you
know for instance we still some
commented out code you know this if
statement is kind of pointless right
since we're not doing anything else so a
few places where we could clean things
up you know I'd rather not ship
unnecessary code if I don't have to so
we'll be on the lookout for that
but for now we want to do some styling
which we basically did you know very
very little styling you up it to this
point I don't even know if we have an
object for styles no we don't okay let's
do that first let's make that so in
react native let me set my timer as well
so I'm going to set a timer for 25
minutes and
I'll do code for 25 minutes and then
when the timer goes off I'll go back to
the live chat I'll answer some questions
as many as I can get to and in a five
minute time period and then we'll do a
little bit more coke
all right so okay we did import style
sheets so maybe we have it somewhere I
just don't know where are we using style
sheets here we go I'm just gonna mix it
in there with everything else so when
you're doing react native it's it's a
good idea to use this style sheet create
and to put your Styles in here it helps
as far as I know with what react native
does behind the scenes it helps with
performance so let's let's move our
styles into our style sheet create
object and then we'll go from there so
that'll clean things up a little bit get
our Styles well in the same spot so if I
take this so this would be our our
inputs it looks like all our inputs have
the same the same styling so I should be
able to select all of them yep and let's
get rid of them and let's say style
equals styles dot input and then up here
in our style object let's create a key
called input whoa didn't not mean for
that time
input and then let's paste oh I wondered
if that was gonna happen since like I
cut all of them but let's paste our
Styles into here okay now what we should
get is our and let's log out so we can
actually see this let's see if it'll
there you go so see these now have the
same styles and we cleaned up a decent
amount of code here because we just move
this into
this works just like a normal style
sheet with a few differences so a normal
style sheet uses CSS syntax right
this is JavaScript object syntax so you
notice we don't have hyphenated
properties here they're camel case if
you take your normal CSS properties and
camelcase them then they'll work and
also we have no values and react native
so there's no pixels at the end it's
just straight numbers okay anything else
is a string we can also throw a
javascript in here which is is a pretty
cool feature and then by default
everything is in Flex box in react
native and the Flex direction by default
is column whereas normally in on the web
the default Flex Direction is row those
are the main differences now react
native uses a subset of CSS which means
that you can't use all of what's
available in CSS and react native but
most of it's still available so if you
if you try to do something that's not
available you'll get a message in you'll
in your browser depending on what you're
using whether a browser or an emulator
or testing on a device at some point
you'll get some warning to say that you
know this one doesn't work at the very
least you'll see on the screen that it
doesn't work right so for now I think
everything we're trying to do will
definitely work okay so let's look
through the rest of our app just to make
sure we didn't miss anything no we
didn't miss anything so right now let's
add some styling to our our links here
or I'm sorry our inputs here the inputs
are really close together which looks
kind of weird so let's add a little
little space between these so I'm gonna
let's add some margin and I'm gonna do
margin vertical this is a little
different you don't see this too often
in CSS but in in react native with our
style sheet we can say margin vertical
and let's just give it an 8 and see how
that looks now what this will do is
margin vertical will add a margin on the
top and the bottom at the same time so
we end up with in between inputs here we
end up with actually 16 pixels or 16
units right of margin and then at the
bottom here we have 8 so I don't
sorry if it there's a little bit of a
delay on the stream my computer's been
doing this weird thing lately where
every once in a while like I can hear my
music like slows down and if I'm
recording a video or streaming it just
like stops for a second or two I haven't
been able to figure out what's doing it
yet hopefully I can just maybe try
restart and that'll fix the problem
alright so I don't really like that much
that much padding and to be honest with
you let's let's give this a little
mobile mobile view here so let's try to
imitate a mobile view and see if we can
get a right now it's showing this under
a device alright cool so we can kind of
see you know how this would look on a
mobile device it's actually looks super
small I think we can definitely make
this stuff bigger wonder why it why did
it look so small did we have it on oh
because I had it zoomed in a lot that's
why so I definitely gonna take the zoom
off of that at least on the on the
desktop or the web version oh no and my
my timer stopped that's interesting I
wonder if my stream freezing in my timer
stopping or have anything to do with
each other I guess I'll have to keep an
eye on the clock now at about 5:30
Eastern Time or about a half hour into
the stream I'm gonna take a break and go
to the go to the chat
all right so let's let's make these a
little bit bigger I want to make let's
make the text bigger as well which I
don't think we have any styles on the on
the text so let's make style equals and
let's say Elia Styles dot oops
heading I've been typing on a different
keyboard all day for work so now I'm
keep miss typing everything so we're
gonna do for our our text whenever the
Styles dot heading whoops nope and let's
give this a font size of I don't know
let's say 24 let's just see what that
how that looks right all right little
bit bigger not too bad and I kind of you
know I want this to be kind of stand out
a little bit more so let's do margin
bottom well we'll give this a 16 for
margin bottom oops forgot my comma see
what that looks like okay a little bit
better all right not bad and actually
with more space there the spacing on
these inputs doesn't look quite as bad
also our inputs are you know a little I
think they could definitely be wider
like right now you can't even see all
the content I wonder what would happen
if we just comment out the width
would it go full-width okay it's it
looks like maybe it's it's defaulting to
some sort of mere preset with I guess
I'm okay with that to be honest with you
though I mean I think we could go like
there's there's quite a bit of white
space here we may want to you know go a
little bit wider especially because the
device ID is is so large there may not
really be a way to fit it in there but
yeah actually just a little bit wider I
think it would it would work so let's
figure out why it's getting this width
and I'm gonna we don't need much space
for the preview right and I'm gonna look
over here I might make this just a bit
smaller sorry if it makes it harder to
see but I want to see what kind of
styles we're getting here and if we go
over to computed so if we look here and
inspect the input right where so we're
on the input and if we go to computed we
can scroll down it's in alphabetical
order and we can go to width and see
like alright actually when it's grayed
out like this this doesn't mean that
they so I want to make sure you can see
it yeah you can see it I was afraid my
my face was covering it up when it's
grayed out like this it means that
there's no width directly applied to
that so I'm I'm guessing that this is
just taking up the full space of its
container so let's check the container
mm-hmm
maybe no it
[Music]
so we're
[Music]
that's interesting maybe maybe we'll get
lucky and just find it in here
[Music]
I'm not sure it's just an it's an odd
number to default to right what was it
defaulting to 152 yes so that is odd and
we can see there's not really it's not
like the container is forcing it to be
there this is the container so the
container is much bigger let's see let's
see what we can do let's see if we can
do some flexbox stuff here so if we do
flex one flex one should stretch this
out I was afraid it would do that
so flick what it stretches out the wrong
way probably because we have it set flex
Direction row that's why all right let's
get rid of the flex all right all right
YouTube's telling me that the stream is
not getting enough data me check my
connection
[Music]
that's weird
connection seems alright let me know if
if anybody's having trouble seeing this
I'm gonna yeah connectionless kid maybe
in about five minutes I'm gonna answer
some questions so if you're in the chat
right now asking questions and stuff
hanging in there for about five more
minutes and we'll wait answer some
questions here let's see I don't
remember if you can do this in react
native 100 percent I'm pretty sure it's
not gonna give us what you want but it's
worth a shot
hey it works now it works now on the web
model higher percent sure it would work
on mobile but that definitely made
things larger and I don't want it I
don't want it to be that big so what we
can do though is we can say with 100 but
then we can also set a max width and we
can see like you know what would we
really want it to be like how wide is it
right now
318 what if we said you know we really
never want it to be more than 280 this
is C 280 see how it looks
[Music]
okay we could probably go a little bit
smaller since we have our device ID
there let's see if we can get away with
like 260 okay 260 that gives us enough
space for our number now the reason that
these little icons are showing up is
because I have LastPass and so it's
shown up there these won't normally show
up unless somebody had LastPass but in
case they do we'll have a little space
form so we got enough space for the
device ID and certainly enough space for
the email and password doesn't matter
cuz you know it doesn't really show up
anyway and
[Music]
let's see
[Music]
I really don't like that these are right
up next to the edge of this so I wonder
if we could do something about that
let's see if there is let's let's go to
our documentation for our text input and
see if there's some way to get a little
bit of padding in between this maybe we
could let's just see if padding will
work that's worth a shot and then we
won't have to go to the documentation
let's just say padding horizontal and
let's give it a four for padding
horizontal let's see what it does
cool all right they gave us a little bit
of padding too awesome
alright so that works it's looking a
little bit better this button says press
me that's not what we wanted to say so
let's change what the button says so we
wanted to say maybe submit see how that
looks
submit lotion also you know maybe we
could do something with the way the
button looks and I think there's
probably some built-in styling options
for this button so we definitely could
look that that up so let's check out
react native button and let's see this
reference here
[Music]
oh cool we have accessibility label we
should probably add that accessibility
label and this takes a string and we
could just say submit I'm that's pretty
straightforward would you know submit
with me okay we could color the colors
for the color of the text in ALS or the
background color in Android
I'm not gonna worry about that now I'll
just leave it as the default I mean just
for otherwise I'm gonna take a long time
to figure out what color I want it to be
so I want to I don't want to do that we
were not working on end end test yet so
I'm gonna leave the test ID out and
let's see what else yes okay it looks
like there's nothing else built-in in
terms of styling just see it's not gonna
show us I was hoping we get a preview of
what it would look on different devices
but doesn't show alright so what we can
do is add style on here so this would be
the last thing we do before I go to the
questions our Styles lock button and we
have another button actually so let's
make sure we add this button and why is
it saying stuff can we not give a style
to this button
[Music]
maybe we can
[Music]
maybe that's it maybe we're stuck with
this this style which is fine I want to
keep this very simple when for the for
the first release you can always add add
in better better styles you know later
on alright so here we go so we have our
inputs and our submit button slightly
better look to it a little bit more
space here and now let me go to the chat
I set a timer here and you know this
this timer that I've been using it's the
Tomato timer calm it's been just
stopping out of nowhere the last couple
of days I might switch it up and go back
or you just have a different timer that
I use but I forgot the URL for it but me
may have to switch it up alright so I'm
gonna try to answer as many questions as
I can
if I accidentally skip your question you
know just like ask it again or put it
down in the comments and I'll try to get
to it alright so I have some questions
people a few people asking what is a
brain computer app so brain keep your
app is just an app that reads your
brainwaves well I should say this it's a
device it's a combination of a device
and an app so this is the device I'm
using it is called the notion brain
computer it's built by a company called
neuro City it's a startup company and
inside of this is the same tech you'd
find in a cellphone and or like an
Internet of Things device you put it on
your head it reads your brainwaves and
then you can send those brainwaves to
wherever you want in this case we're
sending it to our app and for this app
we're keeping it very simple and we're
just tracking the level of focus I
believe it's the gamma waves in your
brain give you a good indication of how
focused you are so we're tracking the
level of focus and if the focus drops
below a certain level
we're changing the color of the screen
and we're making the device vibrate and
so that's what a brain-computer app is
for this project I hope to do some
projects in the future where we do other
things with the data coming out of the
brain but this is kind of a proof of
concept just to show that we can
reliably get data to a mobile device
through a react native app I'm using
react native and Expo so this is kind of
phase one project one of your working
with brainwaves and react native Alex s
if this is going to be posted on the
channel after the livestream ends yes it
will and I will not delete it this time
[Music]
let's see
Rudra asked what is a variable in
programming a variable is a little piece
of data right that you can assign well
it's it's something that you can assign
data to okay so let me give you a I
gotta have a variable in here somewhere
right here we go
so we have Const notion is a type of
variable called a constant that means
that we can't change it after we assign
it a value and we've named your variable
notion and that notion notion holds the
value of a new notion that we've
instantiate it with a particular device
ID all right so a variable could be a
lot of different kinds of data could be
just a string which would be like a word
or a number right it could be an object
it could be an array so this variable
could be a lot of different things but
at its most basic thing it's just
something that you use to hold a value
everybody everybody's saying hello from
different parts of the world how's it
going
Arnav asked what my time zone is I am in
Eastern Standard Time so it's the east
coast of the United States is my time
zone so the same time zone as New York
City that's probably the biggest city I
think in this time zone
[Music]
let's see my Tommy says did you really
delete it I unfortunately I really did
delete the second part of this stream
the second part of this series so very
upset about that like I was honestly
like I felt sick when I realized what
had happened so I mean I there's still
some small hope that somebody on YouTube
will get my feedback message and and
have mercy on my mistake and bring the
video back up but I just from what I
read online I don't think they do that I
think at some point in the past they
used to do that kind of thing but I
don't think they do it anymore so we'll
see
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I'm just looking through
trying to find questions there's still a
lot of people saying hello so
all right so says hello from Brazil hey
how's it going
someone print off says how much money
can we earn in react native depends on
where you get a job from here in the
United States react native developer
could most certainly get a job making
over $100,000 a year it's it's
definitely not uncommon for that to
happen different parts of the world are
obviously very different and you know
different companies pay differently but
it's it's certainly it's certainly
possible to make to make that much which
unless you're in like a very big city
that's that's an excellent salary like
from where I'm from there's not very
many people that that make that much
money so react native can can make you a
lot of money I was born in one of the
poorest states in the United States
which United States a pretty wealthy
country so I guess it's you know it's
not super poor but it's just you know I
don't really know that many people that
made that much money when I was growing
up all right awesome
I actually got through most of the
questions so go back and do some more
code the last another question just came
in right when I said that and it was a
react native versus flutter who wins in
your opinion I I really can't comment on
that because I haven't actually built
anything with flutter so I feel like I'm
not in a good place to comment I really
like react native that can do a lot of
things I've heard good things about
flutter but like I said I can't I think
you could build awesome things with
react native or flutter obviously if I
had to choose something to build a
project with right now I choose react
native because that's what I use every
day and I know it but if I didn't know
either one you know I would definitely
take a look at flutter and and see you
know maybe I would maybe I would use it
alright so let's go back I'm gonna try
set my timer again see if it works this
time
and let's go back in here and I want to
submit and see what our styling looks
like on the once we're like logged in
and the logged in view and also I don't
want to forget something to tell you all
right now so you can remind me the red
flash so we put in the style where like
the screen would flash red if your focus
got below a certain level that when you
first start up the app that red is like
the default color so we don't want that
to happen so I think I'd like to try to
get rid of that as the default color so
we'll take a look at our styles and see
how we can do that but otherwise let's
let's log in and grab a password
cool all right so one thing I'm seeing
here is the focus text is quite small
and it's very close to this logout
button so I think what I'd like to do
here is make this text a bit bigger and
add a little space here between the
focus and logout and that's probably
about it in terms of styling right so I
said we're not it's not gonna look very
like really pretty but I want it to look
like it's not broken or anything like
that and let's see
keep losing my styles objects well I
guess we don't really we want to put a
separate style on our focus text so
because I don't want it to be quite as
big as their heading so style equals
let's just I'm just gonna call it focus
focus text probably not the best name
especially if we reuse this style if we
end up you're using it will rename it to
something a little bit more generic but
for now I think that'll that'll work so
let's say focus text and let's make the
font size let's give it 18 okay that
would be nice nice and big for
readability but then also not definitely
like noticeably smaller than the than
the heading and then let's give it let's
say 8 8 pixels on the bottom between the
button and the focus text so we're gonna
do a margin
bottom of eight I keep saying pixels but
when I say pixels out of habit but I
really just mean like units right
whatever that translates to on a
particular device okay all right that's
that's better a little bit of separation
there we can see what the focus is and
let's see that looks good the only other
thing I want to do is what do you think
about this focus right now the focus is
a number between zero and one do you
think it would be easier for the user if
they saw that as a percentage so instead
of 0.23 if they saw 23% do you think
that would be easier let me know what
you all think in the chat it wouldn't be
too hard to you make that display as a
percentage and then it might be a little
bit more obvious to say like all I'm
100% focused or Miley 20% focus yeah let
me know what you think looks like I got
one yes for that night okay okay we got
a couple of yeses
cool let's let's do it all right so
right now we are showing the focus here
is just the raw data of focus but what
we could do is we could say like focus
and we could multiply that by 100 and
then we can add in a percentage sign and
let's see see how that looks cool 23
percent
okay not not too hard I don't know why
23 keeps coming up as a default like I
have no idea maybe that's just the
baseline that comes through maybe that's
the last value that came through before
I turned my device off last time I don't
know cool
now you notice we still are seeing that
flash of red every time we we restart so
let's look at our styles and see how we
have that set up so it looks like we're
saying the background color we're saying
if the focus is less than 0.2 or 20% and
we have a user then display red
otherwise display white now I don't know
if this will work but it's it's possible
that if we just switch these around
maybe it would read the white first and
we should be able to do that if we just
say if the focus is greater we'll just
flip around these values greater than
point two and we don't have a user then
let's display white otherwise red I
don't have this is gonna solve our
problem but if there's some sort of
solution that might work and it's very
easy to try I'm always up for trying it
and no that did not work at all
that is in fact the opposite of what we
wanted how did I get the opposite
let's see and let's see sorry I got it
somebody's trying to say not nice stuff
so I'm just gonna hide the messages okay
all right so that definitely didn't work
and let's see
I'm gonna look so you got somebody else
is spamming a lot of messages so there
we go
alright that'll clean up the chat a
little bit sorry about that
okay alright what the heck did I do here
well let's go let's just go back cuz
that's not what we wanted there we go
alright should that's better
hmmm
well let me see I'm gonna check the chat
this wall to see if any of you realized
what my mistake was
see AJ hey AJ how's our going AJ is one
of the cofounders of neuro city and who
made this this device so the notion
headset is his last value is that what I
I don't know if he was referring to what
I was going here or commenting on
somebody else okay um all right let's
let me think for a second on how we
could make that work
I'd rather try to avoid the flash of red
if we could but it's not like absolutely
have to have and see so
[Music]
actually if I reverse these colors and
begin a flash gonna flash a white maybe
it would be
[Music]
oh now I know why I did that right
because I said if we don't have a user
[Music]
now I confuse myself alright let's go
back to what I did before so I know for
sure I want focus if focus is greater
than point two I want it to be white for
sure focus is greater than point two I
want it to be white
let's get rid of this for a second right
[Music]
and switch it yeah let's just so folks
greater the point you wanted to do white
and then if user red all right
this is a slightly more complicated
thing but let's see if it works
Wow we still got the flash let's see if
it'll happen if I save again with this
happen oops
alright actually didn't happen let me
actually change something and then we'll
say we're still getting that flash of
red I guess it doesn't matter now what
this does is I just kind of split it up
and added to kind of like two ternary so
it's saying like if the focus is greater
than 0.2 then we just make it white but
if it's not then we go to the the right
side of our ternary and then we check
and see is there a user if there is no
user there's no user then we do nothing
which would make the default color
I guess nothing it would be whatever the
default normally is which I'm assuming
is just white or gonna be red hmm I
wonder if we even need to add white like
what started default without it let's
save that
alright cool yeah so we don't really
even need white so I'm thinking we could
we could get rid of the white altogether
because we don't need it and instead we
could do these ends will switch the
focus back to it focuses lessons all
right we're still getting our our flash
of red that I don't want but we're able
to get rid of our our white we don't
need it I don't see we do have
what we could try to do instead is let's
try this up
well first I'm gonna look at the chat
and see if anybody has an idea it looks
like no but here's what I'm thinking
y'all can let me know what you think
about this idea what if we take out all
of this logic from here and instead in
this use effect which we're already
using to turn on and off the vibration
we use this to change the color and we
can set the color as part of state I
[Music]
don't know I think it's worth a try
in which case let's go up here if we get
any more state we might have to clean
this up a little bit but for now I think
this will be this would be fine
and we can yeah let's clean this up here
and let's say B G color set background
color and we're gonna go use States and
the default background color is gonna be
white FFF and let's see
but you some type stripped stuff here I
think we can say I'm using typescript
but as somebody pointed out to me in the
comments it's a typescript project but
I'm not actually using types so let's
see if we can use types here so what
this is doing let's see if it actually
is doing this yep so right now we're
basically using typescript to say it can
only be white or red we could add more
if we wanted but for right now this can
only be white or red and it's gonna give
us some cool autocomplete stuff
let's check it out down here so we can
set the background set bgcolor and now
we're gonna say we can either do white
or red those are options so let's throw
the option of red and then we gotta set
it back the other way right so if we're
not if we are focused if we regain a
certain level of focus let's reset this
to white cool now down here we can just
set our background color to BG color so
if this works let's see if it works
first if it does I think I kind of like
that better because all the actions that
happen when in terms of a shift in focus
are all located in one place and then we
keep logic out of our Styles so it looks
a little bit cleaner and I totally
forgot to look to see if this even
changed did anything
let's see sweet we got rid of that flesh
now we just have to see like did it
actually work so I'm gonna turn on the
headset
and I gotta give it a second to turn on
and connect right it's starting up takes
just a couple seconds to start it up
once it starts up I'm gonna put it on
and see if we can get that focus down
lower actually if it's stuck at 23 we
can probably change it
let's just let's cheat and just change
it ready hey cool
so we get red and if this was a mobile
device it would be vibrating now let's
switch it back and we get white cool so
now the color is alright and then the
notion is it's starting up so I can see
on my other screen I've got a dashboard
up it's starting the operating system on
the on the headset so it should be
starting pretty soon and there's a lot
going on in the chat so I'm gonna get
back to that in a few minutes here yeah
about five minutes I'm gonna get back to
the chat all right that's cool let's
clean this up a little bit so if the
user cell set user else let's get rid of
this else since we're not doing anything
there
and yes I think that was the only spot
where we had unused code alright cool so
we are connected now I'll put this on
for a little bit so we can get some real
data
okay cool so we should be getting real
data here I've got a an okay signal
coming in oh goodness
all right I just noticed something I
don't know if you caught that on the
screen but we we got a ton of decimal
places out here so I don't want all
those decimal places so let's let's make
sure that we don't we don't have that
and actually that was kind of weird that
that even came on the screen because we
do have this - fixed - that's odd
so setfocus the number we're putting
into focus is actually already with with
to fix so yeah it came up again very
weird which I kind of don't want to show
a bunch of decimal places anyway so
let's just go ahead and add where we get
this focus let's go to fixed you know
maybe when we're multiplying it's it's
messing it up and let's just see can we
do to fix zero is that gonna mess it up
number no to fix
returns a string representing a number
interesting
let's see if we can folks not on the end
put that in the wrong spot there you go
- fixed see if that works alright now we
may or may not see that that number pop
up but I'm thinking that since we're
doing this after any calculation takes
place then we'll actually get to fix to
zero which means we will have no decimal
places so I was cool I'm glad I put the
headset on but see that that particular
bug the Auto formatting on that is a
little weird but cool
[Music]
all right so and my oh my god like
another minute before I wanted to stop
and go back to the channel what I wanted
to do next if I had time we'll start to
get this ready to to go to the App Store
so what I'm gonna do is just kind of go
through what we need so let's go to Expo
and get started
documentation that's what I want so I'm
using Expo to help us build this react
native app so we they have documentation
for so some of the stuff that we haven't
done yet is like this splash screen so
it's just something that'll show up in
the app and so we could add this into
our app and app icon so we got to think
about what we want to do for the app
icon I'm I'm not really any good with
any type of like photo or image editing
stuff so I'll probably just find
something online that like automatically
creates all the icon sizes that we need
that'll be I know there's there was some
documentation that talked about actually
releasing stuff to the app store
I don't know where it went
they were publish your app to publish
all right so there's a couple options we
could do with publish we could publish
through through Expo or could publish
like on my own server so I haven't
decided what I want to do so that would
be the first step and then we would
actually deploy so I'm gonna skip the
Apple Store for now we're going to go to
Android in the Google Play Store and
this is the next step of what we need to
do so we basically are gonna run an expo
command and it's gonna bundle everything
for us so we just need to make sure that
we have our app dot JSON file sorted out
and it has the right info in there and
then I already have an account for the
Google Play Store so we should submit it
like if we get the bundle right then we
can submit it and it says we can do it
manually and then we can actually just
upload it straight from the command line
which is pretty sweet
once we do it manually the first time
and I'll try to do as much as possible
with this on a live stream I don't know
how to do it today because I've been
streaming already for you know over an
hour but the next stream this is what
we're gonna be working on I don't know
how long it'll take to get approved but
you know I'll let everybody know once it
gets get to proofs but basically that's
these are the next steps that we're
gonna do and really I think the hardest
part at this point is just making sure
that our app dot JSON is looking good
and figuring out what I want my app icon
to be because I really have no idea but
I'll show you right now what our app dot
JSON looks like so
right now it's just whatever was the
default which it takes the name from but
the name I put in when I started the
project right so I believe the icon is
like the default Expo icon and the same
way with the splash so we can see like
this icon is just the default that comes
to the project it's blank same thing
with the splash you know rather not have
nothing there but at least like there's
something there right it wouldn't it
wouldn't throw an error saying it's
nothing new so yeah that's that's about
it not really not much else left to do
it so you actually deploy this so now
having said that the only people that
are really going to be able to use this
or you know anybody that has one of
these headsets I mean anybody could
download it but they're not going to be
able to get the brain data right so
it'll be a very very limited audience
and after that there's other features
I'd like to add to this and I'd like to
have it a web version in an iOS version
so those are the next steps for now I'm
gonna go back to the chat and answer the
rest of the questions and let's see I
guess so I'm gonna keep keep tracking my
focus here while we while I answer
questions
let's see me figure out where I left off
let's see finding uses can you tell me
the prerequisite of this course I don't
really know like what the prerequisites
would be like it would definitely help
if you know a little bit about react
native I guess other than that you know
you don't really need to know much in
terms of like the brain computer
interface like it's it just it has a
JavaScript API so you don't need to know
a lot about the internal workings of
what's happening
[Music]
let's see
of a question it says do you have a cat
I do not have a cat
no I have four children in know cat I
have the only pets that I have right now
or two goldfish there behind me
[Music]
[Music]
but see
so there's a lot going on in the chat
but not a lot of questions um trying to
find the questions all right so there's
some some questions and comments based
on the that red screen that kept coming
up when we didn't want it to so thank
you for all the advice on there Amina so
what's the apps purpose the purpose is
to let let the user know when their
focus is dropped below a certain level
it's crazy you can see how much like
trying to go through the questions and
like move back and forth lowers my focus
normally if I'm just coding my focus is
a lot higher than this like more
consistently but but trying to talk and
read the chat really like I guess like
diverts my my attention
[Music]
[Music]
there's a ton of comments about hacking
in here I don't know how he had on the
topic of hacking in here but there's he
I just keep scrolling and it's always
talk of hacking
I'm John is sift through all this chat
to find any questions here's a question
are you using c-sharp I'm not using
c-sharp in this in this application this
is all JavaScript while typescript
technically and so typescript which
actually I just recorded a typescript
tutorial video last night I think I'm
going to put it on my youtube channel
tomorrow so maybe tomorrow morning at
some point tomorrow and so if you're
interested in learning more about
typescript check that out
yesterday I released a video about
documentation for JavaScript and it's
not that long I think it's like less
than less than 15 minutes or 20 minutes
or so but if your shouldn't that check
out my youtube channel the the links in
the description of this video and the
type skip 1 I think the type ship 1 will
be pretty helpful I was thinking about
re-recording it because I made it when I
was tired and I looked really tired and
I keep saying uh and um a lot so if I
don't rerecord it and I just release it
which I might just release it because I
don't have a lot of time and I really
don't want to spend a ton of time going
over the videos because then I have less
time for my family and I just overall
put out less content but I recommend
watching it at double speed because then
it's not quite so annoying that I say uh
and um I'm gonna try to work on that
more maybe I just need to not record
videos when I'm really tired because I
tend to do it more when I'm tired but
that video will come out whether we
record it or in its current state it'll
come out tomorrow and my youtube channel
and I actually think it'll be pretty
helpful
based on what would have been helpful to
me when I started with typescript that I
tried to make the video in a way that I
would have found helpful so if anybody's
interested check it out
I mean says what's the machine you are
using I'm I'm using a PC so it's I I
don't even know what brand PC it is but
it's like Windows 10 PC and where did I
get it from I don't remember
think I got it from Amazon I think I got
it from like New Ager tigerdirect or
something like that
okay I mean clarified I think I mean
meant to say that what what device is in
like this this headset device so this
this is the neuro City notion headset
and in the description I I spell it out
too as well so you can check it out but
this is a brain computer it is a brain
computer or brain computer interface and
inside of it are the same parts you'd
find inside your cell phone and it can
connect to Wi-Fi and it takes all your
your data from your brain and then
provides a JavaScript API so that you
can link it up to your to your app or
your website or whatever whatever you
want to link it up to
[Music]
oh I mean also asked how much does it
cost I am not sure what the cost is
right now because I think they're
working on another model this is just
kind of like a like a testing device
this is I don't know what you want to
call it but this is like the first
version just for developers to work on
and it was $1,000 I don't know what the
price is currently or what it will be
when they start making more of these
kevin says configuring a splash screen
and react native is as dangerous as
eating the hottest pepper in the world
what I hope I can do it
[Music]
Sergey says in 2004 I created a
calculator and basic I thought I'd
become a superstar in the programming
world but I only got older and I still
make calculators that's did exit in 2004
I made a calculator in C++ and then I
didn't code for a long time after that
but I do remember I don't remember
anything else that I coded in that class
but I remember a calculator
[Music]
kevin says is Python or Java better I
don't I don't really know in terms of
better it depends on the application it
seems like python has way more momentum
right now whoa somebody spam in the
channel let's should we keep saying
should we make app using pythons um let
me get rid of let me hide these messages
yeah please don't spam the channel the
question is that was being spammed by at
least two people that I see is maybe
three people was should we make an app
using Python and yeah if you want to
that's it it's entirely up to you
Python is a good language so if if you
feel like that would be good then you
know go go ahead with it
[Music]
someone asked if they could be moderator
album you people were spamming I was
actually just thinking that it might be
good to be to have a moderator it seems
like the last few streams we've had more
people spamming than the normal so I'm
gonna think about thank you for offering
I'm gonna see if if the next stream is
is this bad with spam again then I think
we'll definitely need to to have a
moderator because it makes it really
hard to for everybody in for me to read
the chat and there's no need to spam you
know I get to the questions eventually
all right let's see I can't pronounce
this name but says can you learn a
language in two weeks I know I mean if
you already knew a few programming
languages then you know maybe you could
learn enough about another one to code
but if you were starting from scratch
and you had no idea how to code then I
don't I don't know that you could really
learn a coding language in two weeks
I mean says why did you start YouTube I
I started doing YouTube because I I
wanted to share my work I was working at
a university and I wanted to share my
work with some of the computer science
students there and see if they'd be
interested in and helping out with with
some of the work and I ended up giving a
larger audience outside of the
university and started you know catering
my streaming towards them and then bo
Carnes from free code camp saw on my
live stream and invited me to stream on
the free code camp channel and so that's
that's why I got started basically I
keep doing it because I just hope that
you know my streams would be helpful to
someone else and yeah so I don't there I
don't get any money from this this is
all volunteer even on my own YouTube
channel I don't monetize you know if I
at some point the future like maybe I
think about monetized
like if I really wanted to produce a ton
of content and do it as kind of like a
part-time job I would think about it but
for now it's all just volunteer and I
just I like sharing information and
helping people learn inside out says can
you measure pre and post stimulant using
this app for scientific proof actually
that's kind of interesting I had never
thought about knowing that before but
that would be kind of cool to measure
your level of focus at doing a certain
task depending on what stimulants you
would take like to see maybe if you had
a lot of caffeine does that help your
focus or does it hurt your focus that
would be kind of cool to do so I would
imagine you know you could probably get
some good data on that you'd have to
really make sure that you controlled all
the other variables like noise and like
time of day level of sleep like there'd
be a lot of other variables that could
kind of mess it up but if you did it
consistently then I think it could be
yeah that would be kind of a cool
experiment
[Music]
Amina's my inspiration my favorite go to
resources
yeah my inspiration for coding is like I
just like coding and I I love like when
I hear that some a video that I've done
has helped somebody they that's that's
inspiration right I'm not gonna lie at
first my inspiration to get into coding
was I had a couple kids and a wife and I
needed to pay the bills and this was a
way to make money all right I mean I did
like to do it but it was definitely like
it was how I could get a good job to be
able to provide for my family but now
like in terms of keeping going with the
YouTube stuff is you know whenever it
helps somebody that's that provides me
with more inspiration to actually do
more content I know there's probably a
lot of noise as my kids playing upstairs
so I'm probably I'm gonna try to end the
livestream here in a couple minutes so I
can go hang out with my kids before it's
time time for them to go to bed and
there was I think there's a part two to
that question Oh your favorite go to
resources when I was starting out I used
free code camp a lot and did a lot of
YouTube videos and stuff like watched a
lot of YouTube videos now though I'd say
like my favorite resources are just the
documentation for what I'm using and
Stack Overflow and Mozilla developer
Network MDN of a question how many
programming language do you know slash
understand I mainly code in JavaScript
in typescript I can understand coding in
c-sharp and I've I've worked with in the
past
Java C sharp Python C++ I think what
else
see like I it's been so long since I've
used those languages I don't really know
if I could jump in and code anything in
them right now but I could probably look
at like a simple application and tell
what was going on but I wouldn't I don't
know that I would say that like I know
them you know but if I had to use them
and had a little bit of time to get kind
of like get acquainted with him again I
could probably code something
I mean says do you already have a job
yes I do I have a job I'm a senior
software engineer at a company called
Dick's Sporting Goods MHO 8 says this is
only my second live chat with free code
camp I learned stuff thank you for doing
it oh you're welcome thank you so much
for watching
[Music]
Sergey has to go see you later Sergey
thanks for watching alright alright I'm
gonna I got through all the questions I
think if I miss your question please put
it in the comments below on this video
I'm gonna wrap things up now and go go
hang out with the kids for a little bit
if you if you liked the video you know
please join us again for another live
stream I'm gonna try to do this maybe
Saturday I'll try to do another stream
and check out my youtube channel the
links in the description I just put out
a new video yesterday and I got another
one coming out tomorrow tutorial on
documentation for JavaScript and another
tutorial on typescript and feel free to
follow me on social media links are in
the description you can ask me whatever
you want and I'll do my best to get back
to you
I mean coding related stuff is probably
the best you could certainly ask me
whatever you want but I don't know how
helpful I'll be in other areas of life
but anyway thanks so much for for all
everyone's help all the
nice questions and the chat in the end
the live chat I'm getting really excited
about this project I can't wait to
release it to the app store and that's
going to be the goal for this weekend is
actually get it submitted to the the
Google Play Store and that'll this will
actually be my first app that I'm
submitting to the store so that'll be
that'll be exciting and I'm excited to
actually do it live for everybody to see
and hopefully then that'll help you all
if you're gonna do your own apps but
until then have a great day thank you so
much and stay safe